it's the deflector-in-chief a delusional
Joe Biden giving a rare sit-down
interview and dismissing major problems
plaguing his presidency the president is
not very concerned about Republicans
looking into his corrupt son Hunter
The public's not going to pay attention
to that they want these guys to do
something
it's the only thing they can do is make
up things about my family it's not going
to go very far
but in reality there is bipartisan
support to look into the slimy first son
61 percent support in investigation
and then there's that giant Chinese spy
balloon we just learned some startling
new details the spycraft contained
multiple antennas that were capable of
collecting Communications but apparently
Biden thinks it's no harm no foul
have relations now between the U.S and
China taken a big hit exactly
no
how do you know I know I talked to him
you've talked to Dr Xi Jinping before I
and our our team talks to their people
during this and so I have to I haven't
talked to him during this right and
President Biden downplaying his
classified document Scandal the only way
he knows how by throwing his staff under
the bus
they've informed me not to speak to this
issue to any way try to Prejudice the
investigation that's going on the kinds
of things they've picked up or things
that from
1974 and stray papers there may be
something else I don't know but one of
the things that happened is that what
was not done well is as they packed up
my offices to move them
they didn't do the kind of job that
should have been done to go thoroughly
through every single piece of literature
that's there
Dana I'll go to you first a real Class
Act huh throwing his staff under the bus
and he says they weren't handling it
correctly but what's amazing about that
last quote is that he says items since
1974 which means he clearly wasn't
entitled and maybe for the past 50 years
he's been taking classified documents
and did his staffer put those documents
in the garage near the Corvette okay so
the strangest thing is didn't he just
say that the lawyers told me not to ask
what's in the papers but now he knows
that the papers are from 1974. how could
the papers be from 1974 if they came
from the Penn Biden Center when they
were packing up the Obama
a Biden White House and the Stafford
they are they are it's not just him
that's throwing her under the bus there
was an article the other day saying this
Kathy Chung she's you know she's really
disorganized she was an executive
assistant I'm pretty sure I'm sure she
wasn't disorganized working for somebody
like the vice president so it is
um unfortunate I think for her that
that's happening but I think it also
goes to show that the buck does not stop
with him at least on these particular
things and then whenever a politician
says nobody cares about that you can
assure that everyone one they do care
about it or at least are paying some
attention to it and then you'll be sure
that the media will talk about it and
they'll pull people about it and they'll
ask people and why would they do that
well one reason is because in the last
Administration the Democrats including
Joe Biden raised all sorts of questions
about family ties and money when it came
to Trump and overseas d-lanes and
remember they went after they tried
after Ivanka Trump for China licensing
for making some of her shoes Etc well
Americans have shown that 61 of them do
think that this should be investigated
so they're not being partisan this is a
bipartisan thing and that should be fine
right if you thought when something was
good for the goose I guess it's good for
the gang
and speaking of that Greg I want you to
listen to this sound about that
Americans not really caring I don't want
the polls you're going to have to or I
won't go to you
look at the polls CBS polls 64 of
Americans think the economy is in bad
shape there's an NBC poll 71 percent
think the country's on the wrong track
why the disconnect
because the no the polls don't matter
anymore every time you turn on the news
or any you reporting any positive news
I'm not I'm not meeting you personally
editorally and so you turn on the
television and everything's down
oh man that is deterioration
deteriorating fast I mean I don't know I
mean
trying to think clearly after hearing
that 61 percent said there should be an
investigation into Hunter Biden the 39
remaining are having his baby
you know
he's right about not paying attention
because there's so many other things
going on right the luxury of having so
many scandals and so many problems is
how can you focus when you have
inflation you have crime you have
immigration and then you have his
political scandals whether it you know
it it it that obsesses the media more
than maybe the public would so you just
can't focus on one so that's his luxury
is that he's got a lot of houses on fire
so you may not focus on this stuff it's
a brilliant plan and you stole my other
point I was going to say like about the
family stuff he says you know you you
know if you make up stuff about my
family you won't get very far well the
media and the Democrats went really far
making up stuff and then when you
compare the thing that was most made up
which was the Steele dossier right and
the steel dossier was based on a p-tape
of hookers peeing on a bed that Obama
once slept in probably one of the just
completely fabricated totally
unbelievable and they believe that and
then you flip side to to Hunter where
you actually have video you have videos
you have picked pictures you have a tax
emails emails and they're saying that
that's just Russian disinformation don't
believe that
you actually see it it's real and
they're denying it so the fact is I mean
he might have a point that you know uh
uh people might not care but the BL but
what helped him was the size and the
scope of Hunter's degradations that made
it easy to deny it's like that can't be
true that can't be tritical we'll take a
look at it it is true
all right Jesse let's talk about the
balloon now uh the Chinese spy balloon
that they shot down was capable of
likely capable of listening in on
Americans Communications and pinpointing
the location of those conversing on the
ground and then we've got General Austin
who said earlier that we limited the
communications what does that tell you
it tells me that China knows all the
texts I've been sending about Tarlov and
it's too bad that's going to leak
eventually and it also tells me that
you've been lying to us the whole time
because Biden says he's 100 confident
they got nothing and then the Pentagon
comes out the next day and they're like
pretty sure they didn't get as much
listen Biden was asked are relations
changing since they've been spying on us
and he said no they're the same so
countries can just float balloons over
us and spy on us and it's not going to
change our relationship she goes well
how did you know and he goes well you I
talked to the Chinese and she goes
really and he goes well not recently and
then later he goes well it
you know actually you know things are
changing the relationship has changed
but but he said Austin General Austin
said we limited the comms okay so that
they couldn't get any more
Communications so why did they let it
fly across the rest of the country they
actually said that they needed to knock
it down in the Atlantic because the
water was warmer yeah they said if they
knocked it down and buy Alaska it's too
cold for our scuba divers so we had to
let it take a long trip across the
country to make it nice and toasty for
our our divers I hate Judy Woodruff and
I don't hate a lot of people wow
let me take that back
okay sir it's me I don't
I know why go ahead
the laptop has been verified number one
number two Hunter admitted it was real
and she has the president United States
sitting there and her question is how
are you going to handle the president
how are you going to handle attacks on
you from Republicans that was the
question of all questions and he goes
well none of it's real and no one cares
well a good interviewer would say well
Americans care as the poll says a lot of
them do and what exactly isn't true in
the laptop Mr President is it the big
guy email what is it
she botched it and I'm not gonna let her
go for that oh what did she do to you
Jessica yeah because you're sitting
there with the president okay and she's
a government employee because I I even
said you know it's like it's like your
own employee is asking you questions and
he's saying there's nothing to see here
and she goes moving on and I believe he
proposed an increase in funding for
people for NPR PBS oh you think I have
paid off duty
questioning was weak I thought it was
really weak question but I do retract
and I I never retract I retracted move
smart move Jesse but you know the sad
part about it Jessica is it was his 33rd
interview since he's been president
Obama at this point had 273 and Trump
had 157 I mean you know why is he hiding
I have been an enthusiastic supporter of
him getting out there more I think he
actually does a good job in them I
understand that you were disappointed in
the hunter Biden line of questioning but
people were nervous about the State of
the Union it had 72 percent of people
had a positive reaction to it when he
goes out there and he goes ad-lib off
the cuff whatever it is he usually gets
a bump in the polling that's what
happened uh during the primary and I
hope that he'll do a Super Bowl
interview with us I think that that
would be great and a lot of people would
get to see him you know maybe a more
casual setting came back doing the
American stuff talking about football
also the agenda kicking off your 2024
campaign so I've always been for that in
terms of the balloon we had Republicans
and Democrats who went to the Intel
briefing come out and say that they
think that it was handled appropriately
so whether that's about divers who can't
freeze to death or whatever when they're
going down there or that maybe there's
more going on here than we know because
these people are privy to information
that we can't know which is how it's
supposed to be
like Mitt Romney made it clear he said
was everything absolutely perfect and
how is handled no but nothing in a
military operation ever is so I'm sure
the Chinese got something
so Mitt Romney's in on it
mittens yes it's cheap but but you know
I think the real question is okay let's
assume that that's the case what about
after what did the president say that
scares Xi Jinping well to not do it in
terms of the relations changing right
away right away so blinken was supposed
to be there right on Monday and then you
cancel it until after we heard about it
I I understand that and I know that the
timeline was not satisfactory for many
people it's obviously not ideal if it's
just spotted by people in Montana versus
that they're going to tell us about
something like this but this whole idea
that we can sit here at a table and
understand the Dynamics of tracking a
Chinese spy balloon better than
how dare you
okay I want to Brian Kilmeade I want you
to do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now